big big news involving Donald Trump's
chief propagandist Steven Bannon who
Donald Trump controversially appointed
to the National Security Council at the
start of his presidency he never had any
business being on Trump's national
security council as I told you what had
happened partisan political operatives
especially those with no relevant
experience whatsoever should not be
close to the country's most important
national security decisions Donald Trump
shouldn't be close to the country's most
important national security decisions
but alas he is we have some good news
which is that Steven Bannon has been
kicked off the National Security Council
Trump put out a presidential memo
removing Bannen and restoring the
traditional roles of the chairman of the
Joint Chiefs of Staff and the Director
of National Intelligence to the NSC this
is sort of like the first flat-out good
thing that Trump has done since becoming
president but it's only necessary
because it's trying to make up for a
terrible thing he did weeks ago so it's
kind of like a NetZero isn't it and
remember Donald Trump put Steve Bannon
on the National Security Council
completely by accident he was signing a
bunch of executive orders and he didn't
realize that one of them would do that I
know we reported that that was a
possibility but I don't know whether
that that that ultimately got confirmed
because again because five other
scandals replaced this one I don't know
that we got confirmation but yeah I had
forgotten about the fact that after the
fact Trump tried to say I wasn't even
really sure what I was signing he was
reportedly very upset about it doing
that by accident it must make Bannon mad
that the memo said that his rival Reince
Priebus is now allowed to go to the NSC
meetings any time and the New York Times
is indeed reporting that Bannon
threatened to quit when he was removed
from the National Security Council
imagine being in that room Bannon
throwing a hissy fit about this
threatening to take his propaganda
skills elsewhere maybe back to Breitbart
I guess which is fascinating because now
Breitbart has actually put out an
article criticizing Trump the day after
Steve Bannon is removed from the
National Security Council of course the
abandon formerly the president or CEO or
whatever of Breitbart coincidence and I
don't know I genuinely don't know yeah
and then and may not even necessarily
have to tell bro
Bart to do that Breitbart just may
realize they probably through him still
yeah no doubt about it this is sort of a
win for Trump's new national security
adviser HR McMaster whose anonymous
associates describe he's very pleased
and that it's important and beneficial
for McMaster that Steve Bannon has been
removed from the National Security
Council McMaster didn't have anything to
do with Trump before he was appointed to
the administration and you know in I'm
not saying like I'm a big fan of HR
McMaster but of the people associated
with Trump
I think McMaster is one of the safer
choices to be making national security
decisions he certainly has the
credentials he's well-respected he's
even criticized US military officers
when that's been necessary yeah and he's
also against the use of the term radical
Islamic terrorism because he considers
that to be counterproductive so if he
can influence Donald Trump in that way
that's a very good thing I'm not against
the use of the term but to the extent
that it may be counterproductive I would
I'm fine with it not being used you know
it right I think it's fine to use it in
a media setting or just chatting with
your friends but if you're the president
the United States you have to understand
that these words have big implications
the reality as far as to get back to
banning for a second Bannen as far as we
know unless they're really going to have
you know a disagreement now which is
going to separate them Bannon is still
very closely tied to Trump and you'll
remember that Bannon sat in on that
dinner where Trump casually approved the
ultimately botched raid in Yemen that
led to 30 civilians plus an American
Navy SEAL dying
Steve Bannon was at that meeting and he
wasn't on the national security council
at the time so one thing we do know is
it's not necessary for Bannon to be on
the National Security Council to be at
the table literally when Donald Trump is
making big national security decisions
this is still good but I wouldn't assume
yet although hopefully they're gonna
have you know sort of a what's the
opposite of a bromance like a I don't
know sort of a they're gonna have beef
they're gonna have a beef or something
Bannen can still be very destructive
when it comes to national security even
outside of the NSC discuss this with us
on our reddit discussion forum David
pakman.com slash re d di t will take a
break part two of my interview with
trump confidant Roger stone after the
break